The joe rogan experience.
I just didn't even think that was going
to be a big deal.
I just think that's comics.
I think that I'm used to sitting around
with those guys at the cellar,
you know,
it's,
it's how we communicate.
Like I can't tell you where half of
these guys who were my best friends grew
up,
but I,
I'm ready with so many insults for them.
If one of the mocks back wearing a
stupid jacket,
I can't wait,
can't wait.
Norton is awesome.
God,
Oh,
Norton has crushed me so many times.
Talked about this funny story.
He had a slice of pizza and Louis Ck som
on the street and just slapped a slice
of pizza to the ground
just for no reason.
And he starts to laugh and when he's
telling the story and he's like,
oh,
I was a juicy pizza pizza too.
It was a nice one.
You can do that to another person that
they wouldn't appreciate it.
The humor in the
appropriateness.
So happy.
The other night we were just playing
Keith Robinson.
When he got eliminated from star search,
we were playing it over and over again
in front of him.
By the way,
don't,
don't think that you can come to Amy
Schumer and slap her fucking pizza down.
That's not what we're saying.
You have to be a comedian.
You can get a friend,
a good friend,
but that's so fun.
Oftentimes the best Atell.
Did you see a special road work?
It's so funny.
It's like you can get it,
but it's still happy that he's doing
well again.
His show looks dope.
He's fucking hilarious.
Hilarious.
I don't think there is a funniest guy
alive,
but he's one of my favorites,
that's for sure.
I was saying at the table with my just
saying rounds of venture female comics
and we were like eating dessert.
It was like a really like sad moment.
He just walks up.
We're like,
hey Dave.
He's like,
oh,
what are you guys having?
No boyfriend,
Allah mode,
a vet like Tiramisu.
Satis oh,
that's so funny.
No boyfriend.
Like,
hey Dave.
He didn't even see us till he turned and
then just boom,
fired out as a cat guy
right off the cuff.
Boom.
You just had tell him what Tom tell
story without Kimbo slice Kimbo slice
him ultimate fighter when you were guys
were doing that,
they don't even show this on the air.
So this guy,
I'm not gonna mention his name on the
show,
he lost and you can drink all that
alcohol you want in the house and
there's only at the time there's only
four of us left still fighting Roy
Marcus Jones,
Mitch reone and uh,
myself.
That's the four fighting,
right?
So one of you guys,
one of the other guys is hammered,
hammered.
He's lost,
right.
Hammered,
wasted.
All of a sudden this guy gets super
racist in the house and there's a whole
bunch of black guys in the house.
Start,
stop.
Mountain House wife loves him because
the Iroquois nation and starts throwing
up racial slurs and throwing up these,
you know,
the hit,
hey,
Hitler's Heil Hitler started his name on
this piece of paper for me.
All right dude.
Dude,
this isn't getting out though,
right?
I just need it,
need to know for my own edification.
So he starts doing all this stuff.
I'm sleeping.
I've the biggest fight of my life.
The next day,
Dana white literally stops us in the car
and goes,
listen,
if whoever makes to the finale where we
win or not,
you're gonna be a superstar.
It's huge,
man.
The biggest season we've ever had.
You guys want to win this fight.
Thank you.
No pressure.
So I'm sleeping and
I'm sleeping and uh,
I'm,
I'm sleeping on the ground and I thought
it was a dream.
Kimbo slice and,
uh,
Marcus Jones and this and this d'amico
D'amico Rogers,
uh,
comes in my room.
They go,
yo sharp.
Get up,
down.
man.
I'm like,
Huh,
why are there three large black?
I run my bed.
Kim Goes,
Yo,
man,
this dude's down to talking about our
people.
We're about to jack him up.
I literally,
I thought I was in gym.
I go,
excuse me,
it's talking about our people dog.
Let's go eff this dude up and like,
listen,
uh,
you guys realize,
I said,
I'm,
I'm talking,
I'm not down with the race thing.
I'm totally down to fuck this dude up.
But you realize I'm not black,
right,
Kim?
He goes,
you ain't
no man.
He goes,
damn,
that's crazy.
Turnaround leaving.
I hear.
That's why I like shop.
You can't tell what the hell he is.
I go,
hey,
Kimbo,
that's racist.
Dahlias,
Ypo,
just cause I'm athletic and can file you
gotta be black.
He goes,
you could be.
And
the other day I was,
I was in Venice beach getting launched
and I got a beer and a burger and
enjoyed something that's known in the
state of California to have medicinal
benefit.
And I looked up in the,
uh,
whenever this place was,
this restaurant.
And right over the door was the picture
of Obama from his Hawaii days.
He had the hat on and he was smoking a
Doobie.
And for like a half a second,
I thought,
that's my guy right there.
That's 2008 campaign trail,
Obama.
And then of course,
that's not what we got.
We got smart Bush.
Instead we got somebody who can like
come onto to the tonight show or the
view or something and just have the
host's eating out of his hand by the end
of the interview.
So he's much smarter and more eloquent,
but it's still doing a lot of the crazy
shit that Bush was doing.
And I think that he could still,
uh,
kind of like,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Like,
uh,
come out ahead and like still come
across as a good president.
If you were to legalize weed at the
federal level,
I think most people be like,
oh,
okay.
He actually did something meaningful
that will be around 50 years from now.
And it's not just like,
I'm going to tax,
I'm going to find the shit out of you if
you don't sign up for my healthcare
website.
And,
uh,
I've done more drone strikes than any
other president in history.
I've allowed NSA programs to expand and
said almost nothing in response if you
were even with all that shit,
which I think is awful.
Legalize weed at the federal level and I
would rate him as a good president.
Xi Are Hilarious,
first of all.
I don't think that that's a joint.
I think that picture is a cigarette.
I've looked at it many times.
I've studied it like this approved or
film.
Let's look at it quite closely.
Have you ever noticed this when you're
high?
Like everything seems to be a reminder
that your high,
um,
no because I've been getting high longer
than you son.
But the guys holding it,
I never hold a cigarette like that.
He's really enjoying it.
Yeah.
Let me slows that closing on that bitch.
Let's get a CSI on this map.
Look how many closer.
Look how it's not like,
like it looks squished and stuff like
it's a role joint.
We'll get this smoke signature and you
know what?
Here's a,
here's another,
here's another uh,
point.
Um,
look how far down he's already smoking
it.
He would basically be in the filter.
If it was a cigarette.
You're right.
100% rolled his own cigarette.
He's a cowboy.
Wow.
I know dudes who do that rolled
menthols.
Oh,
how dare you.
He's the commander in chief.
You're a man,
boy,
he's the commander in chief.
You son of a bitch.